congratulations you completed your first
lesson now we've covered a lot of
information here so let's just take a
moment to reflect on some of the main
takeaways first connect your offer to
the world to do this you need to
understand your market so you can make
sure you solve the right problem to the
right audience in second I want you to
focus on the most qualitative segments
first that way you can really show how
to light the fire and make impact
quickly third it's good to have
competitors it shows that someone else
agrees that there is a real need and in
real market for your problem just make
sure you find your unique value or main
competitive advantage you can
differentiate your product with and
finally your value proposition isn't
just a useless exercise it can really
help you connect deeply with your
product and know what's important when
you're pitching it to other people like
customers and investors so we'll see you
next time in lesson 2 and we talked
about what to do before you launch your
app